what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right i'm here with pelina she's got a
sailor outfit on i got the uniform on
everyone knows how it goes
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on the crypto exchange
you can deposit crypto take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
or you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in that interest bearing
account go to blockfi.com
pomp if you've never been to blockfi.com
you should go there right now sign up
for an account i'm an investor
you'll be a happy user like me you go to
blackfy.com pomp what's up
hey what's up okay sorry
sorry guys okay i'm here i am present i
am ready
jp morgan to let clients invest in
bitcoin funds for the first time
the jp morgan bitcoin fund could roll
out as soon as this summer
nydig will be the fund's custody
provider
wow so after jamie dimon was telling his
people
if you if i catch you investing in
bitcoin you are fired
my god i'm sleepy today here we are
one they didn't have purple gatorade at
the store so i had to get yellow
not a good start to the i love yellow
second
is uh jp morgan obviously has to get in
the game you can't
not give your clients access to assets
that the rest of the world has access
you think their wealthy clients are
complaining i think that they've been
calling non-stop
saying hey what is going on with this
bitcoin thing how do i buy bitcoin
they're used to calling somebody at jp
morgan their private bankers and asking
for help
now all jp morgan realizes hey there's
enough demand and we figure out a way to
make money if you notice it is not
a passive vehicle a passive vehicle
would have very low fees
this is an actively managed vehicle it
would not surprise me if it has a very
high fee schedule
and it becomes a revenue source uh and
maybe not a material revenue source at
first
but over time especially if they can get
carry on that fund then you could see a
really really interesting
revenue source kind of be created for
jpmorgan
elon musk said tesla sold 10 of its
bitcoin holdings to demonstrate the
tokens liquidity
while adding that he's retained his
personal investment in the
cryptocurrency
now we know that tesla put bitcoin on
its balance sheet but do we know how
much elon musk owns personally so we
don't know what elon owns personally we
also don't know how much spacex owns
uh uh the rumor is yes i've got from
very good sources that spacex also owns
breaking news over here no we've already
talked about it publicly
uh and elon now is confirming that he
owns some personally as well
my guess is that there's zero chance
that tesla and spacex were gonna buy
bitcoin he personally wasn't gonna buy
bitcoin
he's one of the world's richest men
maybe he bought very little maybe he
bought a lot we don't know but he claims
to not have sold any
and so what i think is really
fascinating is with tesla they're saying
that they were proving that there's
liquidity in the market
uh it also helped them beat the earnings
for the quarter
so let's see what happens but uh
generally i think this was actually
really bullish about bitcoin
uh and tesla continues to be one of the
big proponents in the public markets for
the digital currency sitting on their
balance sheet
sorry i was about to sneeze but i did it
um no sneezing no yawning
what about hiccuping nope
the nfl draft doesn't start until thurs
oh wait
yes oh yeah it doesn't start until
thursday but trevor lawrence
he's known to be like the best hottest
draft pick or something
um i read a profile on him he is making
deals
already making deals like a pro football
player he
is getting his bonus in
crypto with folio
he signed an endorsement deal with
blockfolio blockfolio's a cryptocurrency
wallet
uh and tracking application uh that's
owned by ftx and bankwood freedom the
team over there
and not only did they sign trevor
lawrence but also on top of signing
trevor lawrence they then paid him
his entire signing bonus in crypto they
paid in bitcoin ethereum and so on
in in solana yes what is that it's
another cryptocurrency
i don't know mess with anything but
bitcoin
i'm a bitcoin pro even though i you know
don't own anybody
all right so apple
is unveiling a new subscription podcast
service this is
very interesting um
until now why is it interesting well
because i'll tell you until now apple's
podcast ambitions have mostly been
tailored to courting listeners
but tuesday's announcement was more
focused on setting up a service in which
podcast creators
can better monetize their content you
and i have been saying this
for a long time it is the age of the
creator we're seeing it with newsletters
with podcasts with all sorts of
subscribe
subscriptions subscriptions
um but you know what i'm gonna use this
for i'm gonna make my podcast free for
everyone
and then put a little filter and you
have to pay
just for me yeah i'm the only person has
to pay yeah
why haven't you got that bitcoin well i
have a profile subscription that i paid
for
my wife literally writes the thing and
she makes me pay
it's absurd and she said i have to get
my revenue up that's what she hit me
with i got to get my revenue up you have
to pay
i said what and you have to pay so i am
a paying subscriber of the profile
and i refuse to get a comp now i am
paying you should pay
he was the second one he was mad that he
was in the first but somebody beat him
to the punch
yeah by some loser who probably
unsubscribed already
no they did not all right uh podcast
subscriptions
uh i think are going to be a thing uh
it's just going to take some time for
consumer behavior to change
my guess is that you're going to get
hard pay walls
for the podcast and the whole key to
this is really just going to come down
to
how long will it take for the consumers
to be comfortable paying for
audio and podcast uh it took them a
while to get used to paying for written
content but they eventually got there i
think they will get there
how do you think that this model will be
used
like do you think that people will say
oh for you know
extra special episodes you have to pay
the rest of my content it's free like
how do you think they're going to do it
uh i think that the most successful ones
will be hard paywalls
yeah just like hey you have to pay if
you want to listen you have to pay and
if the content is good enough people
will pay it's hard because you don't get
a taste of the content
that's all well they may put you know
one free every once in a while or
something
the reason i like this is because a kid
in freaking bulgaria
or ukraine or china or anywhere can
monetize this
monetizing well china might not be as
open as bulgaria
wherever you are in the world pretty
much you can you can
you can make money off of podcasting
do you know how many podcasts there are
in the world how many a lot
all right next all right the world's
oldest
known bottle of whiskey is being sold at
a boston-based auction for forty
thousand dollars it is it was
likely bottled 250 years ago
wow i mean forty thousand dollars it's
not that much right yeah
i feel for this kind of bottle whiskey
experience i know plenty of whiskiers
who would
i i feel like it should be way way way
more
the lab said the whiskey was likely
bottled sometime between 1763 and 1803.
i feel like this should go for
yeah quadruple 10x this like 40 000 for
the oldest bottle of whiskey
should we try to buy it no it's less
than one bitcoin
you don't even drink i don't drink but
if i could spend less than one bitcoin
and get the oldest bottle of whiskey
leave a comment if you think if you
think that we should go take a run at
the oldest bottle of whiskey in the
world this is just the auction
starting point people no no no the
auction
late uh it will be auctioned off in late
june and is expected to fetch between
20 and 40 000 nobody is spending 40 000
on a bottle of whiskey you're right i
may spend 41
000. that's plenty of things we can
spend that on
i think that i may take a run at trying
to buy the oldest bottle of whiskey
for no other reason then my wife doesn't
want it because then because you
couldn't get the dinosaur to put in your
kitchen
now i will have an artifact do you want
to tell the people about the dinosaur
no we don't have time for the death and
this is my dinosaur
my t-rex okay so
uh ask lunch money time hashtag ask lm
in the comments below
there were many uh because the last
episode we did was with moist
moist said thank you pomp and pimp for
having me on i'd love to be able to do
it again he's already shooting his shot
thank you to everyone in the comments
for all their support this is just the
beginning for hashtag
moist gang people really
love what they say jake from state farm
is asking if he can please be the next
moyes people are saying this is the best
unleash the moisture there's a lot
but we have a question here okay
tylermills asks hey y'all love the show
it's like cnbc but not boring oh that's
great
question do you have any book
recommendations about blockchain for
someone who is new to learning about it
the bitcoin standard
and also uh bitcoin money you can't f
with
uh both of those books i think are
fantastic you should go read them
and second question how do we tell the
difference between legit coins and [ __ ]
coins like safe moon and others
stick to bitcoin it's the safest one out
there
the safest moon out there no no safest
one out there
all right guys that's all we got hey
i miss all of you oh hashtag moist gang
maybe i should start using that i might
put it in my bio hashtag moist gang
after i buy my bottle of whiskey y'all
are gonna be like damn pomp is on one he
got the bottle of whiskey he's got moist
gang in his profile
and
do you know who would be really happy
he's hanging out look she got a prisoner
outfit
it's not a prison you don't know that
anything see you guys
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends